this video is sponsored by mubi
this is david lynch's first feature film
eraserhead
it follows henry as he navigates a
bizarre atmospheric
and industrial landscape
in his book catching the big fish
director david lynch calls it his most
spiritual movie he explains how as the
film was growing he didn't know exactly
what it meant
he didn't understand how all the
individual sequences came together as a
whole
so he started reading his bible and one
day i read a sentence
and that was it i saw the thing as a
whole
somewhere in the bible is a sentence
that for david lynch fulfills the vision
of eraserhead
and he said he'll probably never reveal
what that is
well what i'm working on today
i'll share with you i'm working on this
thing
that it will hold a telephone the phone
camera on david lynch's youtube channel
he has an ongoing series called what is
david working on today
in this episode he describes his design
for a wooden phone stand
the iphone has these buttons protruding
gotta make a slot so when you slide the
phone in it doesn't activate those
buttons
i think this video gives us some
important clues to understanding the
bizarro world of the films of david
lynch
but we'll come back to it entering the
town of twin peaks first
we need some more context 12 miles west
of the state line
never seen so many trees in my life it
doesn't matter if you've just had a
brief encounter with some of lynch's
work or done a deep dive into everything
this weirdo renaissance man has ever
done
you're probably asking yourself the
question
what is up with david lynch what does it
mean
why is it like this lynch has created
genre-breaking
influential television first with the
original run of twin peaks in the 90s
which broke
open the murder investigation genre of
television with its bizarre mood
and mixture of esoterica and camp my log
saw something that night
really what did it see
ask it and then again with the return
a third season of twin peaks made 25
years later which
is one of the true pieces of genuine
avant-garde television to ever
air
he has a unique body of work across many
mediums
visual art mixed media painting
photography
music interior design as well as books
and a comic strip his work as a
filmmaker is diverse and varied
you'll find a critically panned
self-hailed personal failure
the film adaptation of dune as you
instructed me
i have enlightened your nephews
concerning my
plan my plan the plan
an incredible mess that still radiates a
unique
quality that i've never seen anywhere
else and somehow achieved a cult status
that made back
its budget eventually despite being a
box office failure you'll find a black
and white atmospheric
nightmarish first feature film
his more critically acclaimed dream
noirs like mulholland drive or blue
velvet
[Music]
his fever dream experiment with
self-referential
digital video filmmaking inland empire
[Music]
i can't say this not out loud
this road movie starring nicholas cage
that won him a palm dior at can
[Music]
or his other road movie made for disney
lynch's most linear normal seeming film
but what he calls
his most experimental
from the same mind that brought us this
the good witch
sailor ripley luna loves you
and this
we get this a policeman's dream
yep attempting to understand and
interpret any one of lynch's individual
works
is a feat in and of itself but the task
becomes
almost insurmountable when his work as a
whole is taken into consideration
[Music]
we're cooking quinoa included on the
blu-ray for
inland empire there's a short film
titled david lynch on cooking quinoa
quinoa is something that i like to have
for dinner in this short film david
lynch walks us through his process of
cooking quinoa and this
pan is unbelievable it's super heavy and
lined with
copper it's such a good pan once the
quinoa is on to cook he takes a break
and sits outside to smoke a cigarette
thinking of all those little quinoas
bubbling away and while we wait lynch
tells us a story
back in time 1965
this story framed as if it was just
something that happened to him while he
was traveling once has a bizarre quality
to it
i mean a moonless night
barren landscape where we were in
yugoslavia at that point
and suddenly the train slows
and stops lynch in telling the story
describes things in an atmospheric
and moody detail and he kept filling
filling and filling my hands and the
second i looked up at him
he stopped and i had
trouble getting these coins into my
pockets
and the events of the story take on an
almost magical quality
and then it ends absolutely loved you
know the coca-cola
what time is it
okay and the quinoa is ready
man that is so
good david lynch's style of storytelling
has such a specific quality that the
term
lynchian has become commonplace used to
describe both
lynch's own work and other stories told
in a similar fashion
moths were flipping and flying and like
frogs
frog moths were pulling themselves out
of the earth and
flying up in front of the stand
but what is lynchian
baby my parole was broke 200 miles back
when we burned portage county
are you asking me this question i have a
very good reason
[Music]
what is that indelible quality that ties
together a network police procedural
an avant-garde short film i'm going to
find out one day
a disney movie about a man traveling
across the country on a lawn mower
and a strange story told while some
quinoa cooks it's like a
mysterious strange wind
sound
there is something within all of these
you could call it a tone a mood
a style that connects them despite their
seeming contradictions
it's very much like music the voice is a
musical instrument and what they say is
also very important but how they say it
it's what you say and how you say it
there's a vast network right
an ocean of possibilities and it's a
feel
and and everybody has their own feel so
i use
you know uh my feel we'll return to this
lynchian quality and its importance in a
moment
but let's first take a step deeper into
trying to understand the work itself in
lynch's films and stories there are
often
elements that don't really make sense
abstractions surrealism
and symbolism the meaning of which is
almost never immediately clear
and which on further examination rarely
suggests
on their own concrete singular
interpretations
most people when they encounter this
kind of story do one of two things
discard it as frustrating rubbish or
compelled in some way by the work
go looking for answers to make sense of
it when confronted with material
as abstract and bizarre as lynches it's
an understandable first
impulse to go to the man himself for
answers
you've described it as a film about a
woman in trouble a woman in trouble yeah
you know
i always say this a film is
sort of like a book and books get
written
and the author maybe passes away so you
can't go
talk to them and say what did you mean
you know
that approach by and large in this
situation ends up being a dead end
lynch is notoriously cagey about
explaining
defining or elaborating on the meaning
of his work
and people have a right to
analyze the thing and say what it is for
them and
to criticize it one way or another it's
beautiful
but um i really believe the film
should stand on its own and there should
be nothing added
nothing subtracted that's sort of
the way it is but that's okay looking to
the author's own intent as the
definitive interpretation of a work is a
dubious practice to begin with
but i think for lynch there's more than
just a resistance against explaining
things from his films
often lynch appears to be telling the
honest truth about where
an idea came from yeah you know it's
it's it's strange because
uh the idea is not there and
then suddenly the idea
comes into your conscious mind and it
comes in uh
like an electrical spark and it's known
in an instant that essentially he
doesn't know
this is a book by david lynch about his
creative process and meditation
lynch's creative process seems to be
from his own description basically
plumbing the depths of his subconscious
through meditation and daydreaming to
catch ideas and then
attempting to translate those ideas as
honestly as possible
to whatever medium he's working in i
think the dreamlike
quality to much of his work comes not
from a deliberate attempt to craft
dreamlike images and stories
but from his own creative process faced
with this seemingly
impenetrable dreamlike body of work and
an author who provides
more questions than answers about that
work curious viewers and critics alike
often step into the role of a kind of
armchair psychoanalyst attempting to
understand lynch's work by trying to
understand lynch himself digital
modernism and the
unfinished performance in david lynch's
inland empire
rough beasts slouched towards bethlehem
to be born
eraserhead in the grotesque infant whose
hour has come round at last
desire under the douglas firs entering
the body of reality twin peaks
blue velvet post-modern parody and the
subversion of conservative frameworks
this is just a sampling of the kind of
scholarly film papers that lynch's work
tends to provoke there's an approach to
film interpretation called
symptomatic interpretation to put it
simply symptomatic interpretation
attempts to look at what a film is
saying
about its creators its subject matter or
the societal context in which it was
made
without the conscious intent of the
filmmakers
symptomatic interpretation in film and
literature comes in part out of a
tradition
a freudian dream analysis and
psychoanalysis in general
and so it's not hard to see why lynch's
films with their dreamlike
quality and director who's mute about
his intentions
provokes a kind of armchair
psychoanalysis and
an attempt to understand the work of
lynch by attempting to understand his
subconscious
perhaps this explains the fascination
and obsession
critics seem to have with lynch's
childhood and upbringing
perhaps more than any other director
i've encountered to put it crassly it
seems like people want to know
what kind of childhood trauma lynch must
have endured to produce
such a bizarre and often disturbing body
of work
there are certainly some thematic
connections to be made between lynch's
life
and his work eraserhead's industrial
landscape is so evocative
of the area of philadelphia he lived in
that it's been nicknamed
eraserhood by some residents and lynch
himself refers to the film as the real
philadelphia story
but other attempts at connection like
the attempt to
tie the idyllic oversaturated opening of
blue velvet to his childhood
come up empty blue velvet was inspired
i believe by your childhood in in like
you were born in montana but you you
spent some of your childhood in
no i wasn't inspired by that at all okay
and of course looking to lynch's own
account of his childhood as an
explanation
for his films gets messy because these
stories have their own
lynchian spin to them and in the 50s
where i was
there was an optimism in the air a
feeling of
a bright and shiny future
and there were cars that were very very
beautiful with lots of chrome
there are certainly some shadowy
elements of lynch's life but they're the
kinds of things that happen to plenty of
people who don't go
on to make bizarre dark art house films
instead i think what's more telling are
the stories he tells of finding
oozing black spots on trees crawling
with ants
and that's why i say huge worlds
are in you know those two blocks huge
everything's there everything i think
looking for some large-scale trauma in
lynch's past to explain his brand of
unsettling horror in the present
misunderstands the vision of evil he
portrays in his films
evil horror and darkness in lynch's work
is
always lurking always underneath the
surface
it's often less about an invasive
monster or traumatic event and more
about evil's presence
in the seemingly beautiful idyllic
environments
if you know where to look author david
foster wallace describes
lynchian as a particular kind of irony
where the very macabre
and the very mundane combine in such a
way as to reveal the former's perpetual
containment within the ladder
it's lynch's own perspective on the
world around him
not the specific environments he was in
or the events that happened to him
that shapes the stories he tells and the
way
he tells them and we see our world
and we feel it and we feel there's
things going on
and then sometimes these ideas come
and they string themselves together and
out comes
something like blue velvet
one of my favorites of his youtube
videos is one where he shows some
footage of a worm
in his garden what is to most people
a bug crawling around in the dirt
through lynch's eyes becomes a bizarre
dramatic atmospheric epic
and it came to this sheer rock cliff and
then it would fall down again
and start crawling back up it was
desperately trying to get home and so
looking to events or environments in
lynch's life for explanations of his
work even when you do find connections
doesn't really actually help explain
things it might tell you why eraserhead
is set
in an industrial landscape philadelphia
is maybe my biggest influence or why
coffee and cherry pie and diners are
such a
central theme of twin peaks cherry pie
best in the tri-counties but it won't
actually tell you what those things mean
in the context of the stories or why
lynch chooses to portray them
in the specific way that he does what i
saw
i i've you know carried with me what hit
you
uh the wide range of human behavior
so what do they mean and it holds their
phone in there just
beautifully we're back at the youtube
video i opened with
if you're like me when you saw this you
wondered
why is david lynch building himself a
wooden iphone holder can't he just
buy one you can get one at the store
that works
it's like perfect and then you find out
a few moments later that he
already has one why is lynch building
things he already has
isn't crafting and designing another
version of something that you already
have
fairly pointless meaningless even i
think the answer
is important to understanding his work
as a whole
and how to get the most out of his films
as a viewer but it's so much fun to
build
our own things and um
solve the problems and figure out a way
to do it on our own
it's about the process the meaning
itself is not in the utility
of the outcome but in the specific way
you
do something if you turn the camera a
little bit to the left it would be wrong
you'd see something that broke that but
broke the mood and and made it incorrect
but you turn it right there it's it's
talking to
it's saying it's it's exactly feels
right when mark frost and david lynch
set out to make twin peaks a tv show
about a murder mystery they never
actually
intended to solve the mystery they only
eventually did so under pressure from
the network but
from the start the goal was always
mystery
for its own sake there's a line in twin
peaks fire
walk with me we live inside a dream we
live inside a dream yeah that's a very
lynchian
no it's sort of the truth it's not about
what the stand
does once it's finished but about the
feeling and quality
it possesses as a result of the process
of crafting it
those feelings and qualities that lynch
is looking for
and bringing to light along the way are
what define lynchian
to fully appreciate a piece of lynch's
work i think you need to largely let go
of the idea that it's building towards
some
specific meaning like the iphone stand
it's not about where you are at the end
but about the process of getting there
it's about immersing yourself in a mood
a setting
a feeling and letting that wash over you
if that sounds ridiculous or pretentious
to you consider that you've already
experienced engaging with art in this
way
in other mediums songs with very
abstract lyrics or no lyrics at all
paintings with no discernible plot
setting or even
objects architecture that can evoke a
very strong feeling but that doesn't
have a clearly interpretable symbolism
we engage with all kinds of art without
requiring
a clear single interpretation and
meaning
but for some reason that's the way most
people like to engage with film
i i really would like to um
be able to explain but the film
ends up being the explanation
process of attempting to interpret or
understand a film
usually involves uncovering hidden
meaning and expressing that and to do
that it requires
an interpretation of that meaning into
words
but lynch is trying to convey feelings
and ideas that
aren't easily expressed via words that's
why
cinema for him is the perfect medium for
those ideas
the feeling is the meaning to understand
his films
you have to feel them
of course attempting to interpret or
find a meaning in his films is
completely valid
but i'll let lynch himself explain to
you why you don't need my help
understanding his work cinema is a lot
like music
it can be very abstract but people have
a yearning to make intellectual sense of
it to
put it right into words and when they
can't do that it feels frustrating
but they can come up with an explanation
from within if they
just allow it as they start talking to
their friends
soon they would see things what
something is and what something isn't
and they might agree with their friends
or argue with their friends but how
could they agree
or argue if they don't already know the
interesting thing is
they really do know more than they think
and by voicing what they know it becomes
clear
and when they see something they could
try to clarify that a little more and
again
go back and forth with a friend and they
would come to some conclusion
and that would be valid lynchian is a
term we generally think about in
relationship to narrative work but i've
definitely seen
documentaries that qualify as lynchian
one of those documentaries is the
documentary
leviathan which visually documents a
fishing boat but it does so with such a
specific mood and atmosphere that the
documentary takes on
a really interesting quality it's really
more about the way the thing is
presented than what
exactly is being presented and you can
watch it right now on
mubi in the us mubi is my sponsor for
this video
mubi is a hand curated streaming service
with an excellent
ever growing selection of great
international
independent art house films and classics
you're going to find a lot of great new
stuff on mubi
and it's available all around the world
i've been talking about movie for a long
time and i'm always excited to continue
talking about it because
i use it to discover great stuff all the
time
right now the canned film festival is
happening and mubi is doing a special
series
showcasing work from past canned
festivals every day a new film is added
that's hand
chosen by a human because they think
it's worth checking out so
go check out mubi start watching some
new films discover
something new go to mubi.com
thomasflight to start your 30 day free
trial you can watch leviathan or check
out something else just go to movie.com
thomasflight the link in the description
will get you there support my channel
and give you access to a 30-day extended
free trial of mubi
thanks again to mubi for sponsoring this
[Music]
video
[Music]
do